bonjour à tous 33 mille habitants et 39
élus au conseil municipal dans trois
semaines les électeurs des mureaux
seront appelés aux urnes pour élire
leurs maires
s'ils sont cinq candidats à s'être
déclarés pour le poste 2 directement
seulement ont accepté de débattre sur tv
78 radio sensations nicolas brève leçon
et hervé riou bonjour il y à aussi
daniel larrouy bonjour alors vous êtes
co listier de alain lugué candidats de
lutte ouvrière merci de vous être
déplacés
tous les trois évidemment on a essayé de
faire venir les cinq candidats françois
gare et le maire sortant et tête de
liste les mureaux une ville à vivre n'a
pas souhaité participer à cette émission
agnès étendard tête de liste agir aux
mureaux n'a jamais répondu directement à
nos nombreuses sollicitations il nous a
été impossible de la joindre pendant
plusieurs semaines un membre de son
équipe nous a tout de même informé hier
la veille de ce débat du coup qu'il
était impossible de se déplacer à cause
de son agenda
voilà pour les présentations je vous
rappelle que vos temps de parole seront
chronométrés pour pour ce débat pour
pour l'équité et qu'un tirage au sort a
été effectué en vue de la première prise
de parole
on commence avec vous c'est le tirage au
sort qu'il a choisi nicolas brisson vous
êtes du coup tête de liste rassemblons
rassemblons nous pour les mureaux à 29
ans c'est votre première expérience
électorale arrivé il ya peu aux mureaux
vous étiez auparavant engagé au sein de
la section locale du rassemblement
national dans le val d'oise
vous avez toujours voté pour ce parti
depuis votre majorité dites nous
pourquoi les muriautin devrait vous
faire confiance et voter pour vous le 15
mars prochain
tout simplement on est la première le
premier parti d'opposition actuellement
actuellement nous avons quatre
conseillers municipaux
donc nous connaissons quoi nous essayons
parce que monsieur gare est assez obscur
dans ces conseils municipaux ne nous
connaissons le mieux les dossiers
possibles
après bon je voudrais aussi commencé
tout d'abord déjà par vous remercier
déjà de cette invitation que je suis
assez déçu qu'on ne soit pas tout seul
aux estables donc les murs y autant on
est des murs yotine ont voté pour nous
sur les élections européennes ils ont
placé en tête
donc s'il faut il cherche à changer de
deux mers il ya une très grande demande
sur ce côté là beaucoup sont déçus par
monsieur garret et donc voilà s'il faut
du changement je leur conseille de voter
pour nous hervé riou vous êtes la tête
de liste les mureaux pour tous
professeurs en classe préparatoire vous
est aussi président du cercle aquasports
est des mureaux sur votre liste internet
il est indiqué que vous êtes soutenus
par quatre partis au mouvement écologie
bleus génération terrain les
républicains et libre a expliqué nous
aussi pourquoi les habitants des mureaux
doivent-ils voté pour vous le 15 mars
eh bien écoutez ça fait maintenant plus
de sept ans que je veux voir les
habitants de la ville des mureaux est
évidemment depuis plus d'un an de
manière systématique quasiment
quotidiennement tous les échanges avec
les milliers de personnes que j'ai pu
aller rencontrer me font prendre
conscience de deux réalités
la première c'est que cette ville
souffre elle souffre du fait que les
problèmes existent toujours
on a toujours les mêmes problèmes
d'éducation a toujours les mêmes
problèmes de transport les jeunes
n'arrivent pas à trouver d'emploi
la ville est pas du tout attractive au
sens économique du terme
et ça depuis 20 ans bien et puis le
deuxième grand enseignement que je tire
de ces milliers des changes avec des
habitants de la ville
c'est que il y a une énorme volonté de
changement les habitants ne veulent pas
forcément renier ce qui a été fait ils
veulent juste que leur propose un avenir
beauchemin pour cette ville des mureaux
qui leur permettra de régler les
problèmes que je viens de citer
et moi je suis convaincu d'une chose
c'est que pour régler les problèmes que
je viens de citer qui sont des problèmes
structurant pour la bulle numéro il faut
du courage la volonté politique de faire
avancer les dossiers et le soutien
institutionnel pour y arriver parce que
si vous n'avez pas vous aurez beau faire
des promesses qu'ils ne pourraient bien
faire il se trouve que nous moi et mon
équipe nous avons ces trois éléments
daniel larrouy vous terminer ce premier
tour de taille vous êtes donc colistiers
et donc inscrit sur la liste d'alain
huguet candidate de lutte ouvrière est
tête de liste faire entendre le camp des
travailleurs pourquoi les habitants des
mureaux doivent-ils voté pour vous dans
trois semaines
bonjour oui effectivement ça sera voté
pour nous ça sera voté pour le cas des
travailleurs comcom est nommé la liste
parce qu'en fait elle n'est composée que
de travailleurs du ram ou de retraités
travailleurs aucun politicienne
professionnel auquel notable c'est la
seule façon qu'on aura de voter pour une
liste intransigeante pour des militaires
mme intransigeant de la classe ouvrière
qui porteront les intérêts des petits
jam des travailleurs des chômeurs des
retraités etc ceux de la seule façon
aucune intransigeance pas de concessions
et regarder tout du point de vue des
travailleurs
voilà c'est la fin de ce premier tour de
table merci à vous première thématique
de ce débat l'éducation et la jeunesse
les mureaux est une ville que l'on peut
qualifier de jeunes plus de 45 % de ses
habitants ont moins de 30 ans selon les
chiffres de l'insee sur le territoire de
la commune il ya onze écoles
élémentaires et 11 écoles maternelles
publiques l'ensemble de ces
établissements est classé en zone
d'éducation prioritaire
alors quelles sont vos propositions et
idées pour l'éducation pour la jeunesse
sachant qu'un projet va structuré et
structurant pour la ville devrait
débuter c'est le futur paul léo lagrange
prévu pour 2009 21 initialement et qui
devrait être équipée d'un grand complexe
sportif et d'une vingtaine de classes
primaires sur sur le territoire daniel
larrouy
lutte ouvrière quelles sont vos
propositions pour la jeunesse pour
l'éducation aux mureaux l'éducation la
jeunesse effectivement c'est une
priorité ça va être une parité de tout
temps qu'est ce que c'est le futur mais
faut quand même être réaliste maire de
ce point de vue là a très peu de pouvoir
tout se décide ailleurs les budgets les
programmes le nombre d'heures devant les
élèves
les budgets pour entretenir les locaux
et ça c'est un dehors des mérites
alors les mairies elles font ce qu'elles
peuvent c'est une charge les écoles
maternelles et des écoles primaires
elles sont à charge bien sûr mais on ne
leur donne pas suffisamment de budget
pour potes pour tenir sa part ailleurs
et bien ou bien ailleurs décidé de
réduire le temps de présence des
enseignants devant les élèves
la conséquence c'est l'augmentation des
effectifs dans les classes c'est
l'impossibilité de s'occuper au cas par
cas des élèves en difficulté eh ben
c'est ça que dénoncera de renom seront
des élus lutte ouvrière c'est comme ça
qu'ils regarderont la situation et pas
autrement pas en essayant de faire des
découpes et d'aider moyenne là où il n'y
a pas lieu d'en faire ce que vous
n'arrivez pas avec des propositions
forcément toutes faites vous souhaitez
plutôt contesté et peser sur les débats
âgées si je comprends bien nationaux
plutôt n'ont pas forcément que nationaux
mais bien sûr aussi avec toutes les
autres listes qui se présentent
lutte ouvrière un peu partout en france
il y en a 250 liste en fait notre notre
objectif c'est de fédérer d'organiser
les travailleurs là où il somme pour
qu'ils gèrent eux-mêmes les problèmes
qu'ils prennent en main leur situation
et amène toute la société sans exception
à la base sur leurs propres intérêts
nicolas brisson pour la jeunesse et
l'éducation aux mureaux quelles sont vos
idées fortes vos propositions
nous nos propositions déjà d'avoir le
cadre à l'école le
le mieux possible pour pouvoir apprendre
donc on va déjà se seraient déjà
pour les écoles refaire qu'elle soit
entièrement rénové voilà un maximum pour
avoir le cadre le mieux pour pouvoir
travailler
maintenant c'est vrai que la politique
nationale fait que les classes sont de
plus en plus surchargées bon il ya le
dédoublement maintenant des classes de
cp qui donne le tempo de la ccpc 20 aux
mureaux sont dédoublés voilà ce qui
donne serait qui ont pour certaines
villes c'est un problème parce qu'il a
fallu construire de nouvelles écoles et
et après donc on a aussi un cheval de
bataille c'est sur la cantine scolaire
donc faire manger aux enfants ce ça
reste dans l'école l'éducation faire
manger aux enfants le plus possible de
produits locaux
on est un territoire n'a levé que cendre
que je pense qu'on a ce qu'il faut dans
notre petit coin pour pouvoir faire
manger les enfants s'en sent le phare à
importer les produits de l'autre bout du
monde quoi hervé riou vos propositions à
vous alors j'ai noté parmi eux de
nombreux points que vous souhaitez créer
un pass sport club pour favoriser
l'accès des jeunes au club sportif c'est
vrai si je reviens sur l'éducation
moi ce que je constate c'est que
l'éducation à les sinistrés sur les
numéros et j'apprends que dans des
écoles
il pleut j'apprends que dans des écoles
il n'y a pas assez de chaises de ta pour
faire asseoir tous les élèves
j'apprends encore des écoles il fait
froid parce qu'il n'ya plus de chauffage
pourquoi on en est arrivé à une telle
situation
c'est simple c'est parce que
l'investissement sur les écoles a été
supprimé donc moi la première chose que
je ferai si je suis maire c'est que je
rebascule de l'investissement
prioritairement sur l'école ensuite
c'est vrai que dans l'école il y a les
politiques nationales
il ya aussi les politiques locales moi
je souhaite accompagner les deux parce
que je ne vois pas forcément l'une
contre l'autre
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que tous
les professeurs en qui j'ai une grande
admiration parce que vous l'avez dit
j'en suis un je sais à quel point ce
métier est compliqué tous les
professeurs qui souhaitent faire des
activités qui permettent aux élèves de
la bulle des mourres de sortir à
l'extérieur je les soutiendrai pourquoi
parce que moi ce que je veux c'est que
les élèves aillent voir le château de
versailles
je veux que les élèves de la vie numéro
à y voir la tour eiffel
je veux qu'ils aillent dans des
entreprises je veux qu'ils aillent dans
des musées donc je rétablirai les
classes de découverte
tout à l'heure vous avez dit que toutes
les classes étaient des doublés sur la
mini bros c'était pas vrai elle ne
respecte pas le référentiel de
l'éducation nationale il y a deux
professeurs par classe alors que le
référentiel du bien à ce professeur face
à 12 élèves
et puis pour l'éducation je pense que il
faut avoir de l'ambition dans cette
ville et ne pas se limiter uniquement
aux élèves des classes maternelles et
élémentaires et donc moi ce que je
propose c'est que pour tous les élèves
de la ville des mureaux qui sont
talentueux
j'ai eu l'occasion de me rendre compte
lorsque je suis allé les rencontrer
je propose d'inventer une poursuite
d'études de l'enseignement supérieur
dans cette ville sur quels domaines il
faut y réfléchir
néanmoins je trouve que le domaine de
l'ingénierie et de la santé s'y prête
parfaitement puisqu'on a des centres
hospitaliers ainsi que l'aéronautique et
l'aérospatiale avec la présence d'airbus
sur le territoire donc avec la région
qui me soutient on apportera une bourse
d'étude avec un centre des métiers et
des qualifications
merci à hervé riou vous avez un peu
d'avancé sur le temps de parole je vais
peut-être vous faire réagir tous les
deux nicholas bray psoe daniel la
rouille sur ce projet local pour le coup
c'est le pôle le pôle léo lagrange qui
devrait arriver en 2021 qui aura
peut-être sûrement du retard
c'est un grand projet pour pour la
mairie qui le façonne depuis des années
une vingtaine de classes primaires
seront construites et maternelle aussi
un grand complexe sportif c'est
plusieurs milliers de mètres carrés
plusieurs hectares est-ce que vous c'est
un projet que vous soutenez nicolas
brisson qui assure la majorité a soutenu
ce pas la majorité
au contraire notre position notre open
l'opposition était derrière tout ce qui
concerne l'éducation de là vers
l'investissement qu'ils avaient à faire
ça fait partie des investissements qui
sont prioritaires
donc bien sûr qu'on était d'accord avec
cela
après donc c'est à dire en continuité
avec 1000 continues tu es complètement
sur tout ce qui est
dois dire des investissements utiles qui
va permettre de pouvoir accueillir des
enfants sur plusieurs décennies
on est toujours tout à fait pour toutes
ces genres de choses quoi daniela ruah
votre position sur ce sujet précisément
très local c'est le léo lagrange le pôle
léo lagrange il n'y a pas de raison de
s'opposer
franchement à éteindre les possibilités
d'éducation à augmenter la surface
disponible parce que comme ça a été dit
juste maintenant effectivement les
classes sont dédoublés mais ya pas assez
de cap assez de salles pour faire court
et donc en fait ça correspond pas à une
des deux classes ça correspond à un
doublement du nombre d'enseignants dans
la même salle qui n'est pas forcément
l'idéal mais ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas mais ce qui arrive parfois aux
mureaux particulièrement oui parfois
voilà donc oui il n'y a pas de raison de
s'opposer à la construction et à finir
la construction et les équipements de ce
type là mais pour nous ça sera quand
même sans illusion si derrière les buts
je suive pas pour l'entretien si
derrière on n'a pas le personnel pour
l'entretien si derrière on n'a pas tout
ce qu'il faut pour encadrer pour former
y compris dans le domaine périscolaire
et bien là on lèvera le doigt on
mobilisera la population les enseignants
les travailleurs de l'entretien pour
justement avoir une offre de qualité et
tout ce qui fait que on peut enseigner
est allé loin dans les études parce que
c'est le milieu social complet qui porte
sa s'est pas uniquement l'école c'est
tout ce qui l'entourent c'est le
quartier c'est la ville c'est la famille
avérée ou si vous souhaitez peut-être
oui ou non nous dire votre position sur
sur léo lagrange vous êtes un peu en
avance donc ce sera assez rapide comme
comme réponse c'est rapide évidemment on
ne peut que se féliciter quand on
travaille pour l'école mais néanmoins
j'aimais de réserve la première réserve
c'est que si j'en crois ce que j'ai lu
dans les comptes rendus des conseils
municipaux ses 17 millions d'euros c'est
paul léo-lagrange
or si on compare au pôle molière qui a
fait des dépassements budget on en
arriverait peut-être 24 bon là le but
selon la mairie c'est de tout financé
grâce aux collectivités et 8
j'émets quelques réserves excusez-moi
bon néanmoins néanmoins on est sur une
de deux échelles de temps il a
l'immédiat il y a un projet ambitieux
comme le pôle et au la branche galerie
revendre entre 4,50 moins dans
l'immédiat ce qu'il faut c'est faire en
sorte que les élèves des 2 1 à la
rentrée scolaire 2020 en septembre
puissent travailler dans des conditions
dit au sentier du katif et donc la
priorité c'est de remettre
l'investissement budgétaires sur les
écoles existantes pas sur les échos le
futur aussi on va passer à la deuxième
thématique de cette émission le social
peut être regardée voalavo autant de
paroles où on voit que hervé riou un peu
d'avancement va réussir à équilibrer je
compte sur vous ce temps de parole sur
le reste de l'émission autre sujet
important pour les mureaux corrélé à
cette thématique aussi de l'éducation
c'est l'action sociale toujours selon
les chiffres de l'insee de 2016 le taux
de pauvreté aux mureaux et de 26 %
contre 10 % sur l'ensemble du territoire
des yvelines le taux de chômage atteint
près de 20% malgré tout de même la
présence 1 / / / cette commune de grands
groupes comme ariane ou renault juste à
côté à flins comment vous comptez du
coup aider ceux qui sont dans des
situations économiques sociales et les
plus fragiles
nicolas bref selon vous si je prend
l'une de vos propositions pour cette
campagne c'est baisser la taxe foncière
de 5 % la taxe foncière la part
communale qui revient de 5% je suppose
que c'est pour redonner du pouvoir
d'achat aux habitants sait déjà c'est
une des demandes des habitants
les trois préoccupations majeures oui
sont sont ils veulent la sécurité la
baisse des impôts ça fait partie des
préoccupations majeures
donc nous après voilà il faut pas on va
pas promettre la lune
si on fait une baisse d'impôts mois
passent ailleurs on ne pourra pas créer
des nouvelles infrastructures des choses
comme ça donc on va rester sur ça donc
déjà la best la baisse des impôts de 2
5% sur les impôts locaux
ça va déjà donné un petit peu de pouvoir
c'est pour les prochains mois une ceux
qui ne sont pas propriétaires est ce que
l'om c'est que là la taxe d'habitation
ne sera plus payé donc on peut pas voler
social dans le domaine social pour
peut-être aider au retour à l'emploi
soutenir les plus fragiles ceux qui
vivent en dessous du seuil de pauvreté
qui est de 26 % le taux de pauvreté à
aux mureaux pour eux que vous avez des
idées concrètes alors proposé là pour
l'instant on était plutôt sur les
personnes âgées les personnes âgées sont
énormément dé laisser aux mureaux bon là
il ya la construction de maisons de
retraite qui va se faire maintenant bon
c'était un projet de monsieur garé sur
le mandat et les constructions vont
peut-être commencer seulement maintenant
les personnes âgées sont délaissés ne
connaissent pas leurs droits
certains prennent le taxi pour aller
faire alors que leurs courses
normalement il ya des navettes mais bon
ça que j'en ai jamais vu encore sur les
murs ou donc ça serait un point à régler
ce sera déjà remettre de l'ordre dans le
ccas que voilà que les personnes
connaissent leurs droits et faciliter la
vie des personnes âgées aux mureaux
daniel larrouy pour lutte ouvrière
quelles sont vos propositions pour aider
ceux qui sont sans emploi les familles
aussi monoparentales les plus fragiles
souvent ou encore les seniors également
pour le social je vais prendre deux
exemples parallèle tout d'abord le
social c'est qui gangrènent surtout la
vie de la vie de la population
laborieuse c'est le chômage c'est la
précarité et dans votre entrée en
matière vous preniez un exemple une
grosse société qui est présente sur sur
la commune des mureaux c'est ariane
groupe aujourd'hui ariane groupe
supprime un quart de l'effectif ya pas
de l'indus pression d'un plat il ya
juste des départs non remplacés
ça va durer jusqu'à jusqu'en 2023
avant-hier au niveau du groupe airbus
défense espèces il annonce la même chose
alors aujourd'hui retour à l'emploi
mais l'emploi il va falloir imposer aux
entreprises d'embaucher parce que c'est
le meilleur inverse qu'il faut mais ça
vous pouvez le faire à l'échelle d'une
commune un verre à ce pouvoir là de bien
sûr que non un maire n'a pas ce pouvoir
là par contre mr il peut prendre là il
peut prendre le l'initiative d'organiser
les travailleurs dans l'entreprise pour
contester ces plans là parce qu'il ya
des surcharges de travail parce qu'il ya
des les bernanke partout dans la boîte
et les regrouper avec les chômeurs avec
les précaires pour aller imposer une
boîte qui qui est il utilise pardon les
églises équipements payés par la mairie
les routes le ferroviaire tout ça c'est
c'est du ressort des impôts
les entreprises elles utilisent ça elles
veulent des baisses d'impôts elle refuse
de payer les taxes qu'on appelait un
professionnel bah ouais ben ils
utilisent toutes ces infrastructures sur
nos impôts bas on peut le dénoncer on
veut regrouper les gens autour de ça et
il fédérer pour faire pour leur imposer
aussi des embauches à ce niveau là et
l'autre volet c'est l'hôpital l'hôpital
même chose on est en train de supprimer
des services supprimer des postes
et là le maire il a son rôle à jouer il
est au conseil d'administration qui
pourrait
prendra la parole et come back du centre
hospitalier intercommunal de meulan les
murs au oui non je précise pour ce qui
force à part peut-être ne connaissent
pas à l'antenne
oui c'est cela donc en fait le maire il
est au conseil migration de droit eh
bien il peut regrouper autour de lui
avec lui l'ensemble des travailleurs
hospitaliers c'est à dire les soignants
éléments soignants et redévelopper
redemander dès budget y aller les
chercher les obtenir par la mobilisation
des travailleurs
hervé riou si je me base sur votre site
internet vous souhaitez développer une
politique qui vise à l'humanisme
l'autonomie la responsabilité et
l'émancipation alors concrètement qu'est
ce que donnent ces quatre mots combinés
en termes de mesures pour le social
concrètement là j'ai fait du copier
coller est ce que vous avez copié collé
est tout à fait correcte dans le concret
tant il ya deux champs sur l'action
sociale
il y à aider ceux qui sont dans le
besoin et bien sûr il faut les aider
et puis ceux qui sont sur un chemin d'en
sortir il faut leur permettre d'avoir
une vie digne notamment leur permet
d'avoir facilement un emploi pour ceux
qui sont dans le besoin
moi ce que je propose c'est de créer des
centres sociaux lors où on en a besoin
or il y en a un dont tous les murs le
times parle qui a disparu c'est le
centre alpha dans le quartier de la
vigne blanche qui a priori et est juste
exceptionnelle en terme de
fonctionnement toujours utile que tous
ceux qui ont pu bénéficier des actions
qui le proposait à l'époque en garde des
étincelles dans les yeux donc moi je
propose de recréer ce centre alpha en
parallèle de cela je vais créer des
conseils de maisons par quartier dont
l'objectif sera de définir avec des
habitants de chaque quartier
les missions prioritaires de chaque
centre social et puis je vais mettre en
place un plan anti isolement des
personnes qui sont trop isolés dans la
ville soit parce que l on vit un drame
de la vie soit parce que l'âge avançant
elles sont de moins en moins mobiles
donc là il faut inverser la logique des
services s'ils ne sont plus à ces
personnes d'aller chercher les services
à la mairie
c'est à la mairie dès les chairs pétales
et proposé ses services et les amener
chez les petits ces personnes là donc
nous proposerons ce genre de service et
puis pour l'emploi parce qu'il faut
c'est ramener l'activité économique sur
la ville et simplement savez moi je suis
allé voir les marques et marques
vestimentaires les marques alimentaires
fall est grande
je leur ai posé la question mais
pourquoi vous venez pas sur la ville des
mureaux si nous répondons ne dise on
vient pas parce que c'est compliqué donc
ce qui vous faire c'est simplifier les
démarches d'installation pour refaire
vivre
l'activité économique de cette ville et
puis il faut se tenir tous les poumons
économiques bougimonts les pléiades
cette zone économique là bas il faut les
accompagner dans le développement de
manière à ce que l'emploi sera créé avec
priorité aux halles embauche d muriautin
et puis dernière chose pour les budgets
de la ville que je vais dépenser là
aussi je vais donner la priorité aux
entreprises des mureaux donc chaque
centime dépensé sera en priorité utilisé
pour faire vivre les entreprises on aura
l'occasion de parler de budget et de
dettes dans la suite de cette émission
n'hésitez pas à chaque fois appelé à
répondre à ce qui est ce qui est dit sur
ce plateau nicolas bref si vous avez un
peu de retard est ce que vous souhaitez
revenir sur ce sujet du social après je
préfère plutôt récents fait la priorité
vraiment de la commune c'est le budget
donc je préfère garder ici pour le
budget ce sera notre quatrième
climatique
la troisième c'est le cadre de vie on
poursuit ce débat du coup sur le premier
tour des élections municipales au mur au
débat diffusé sur tv 78 radio sensations
également et on va aller à présent vous
allez à présent nous exposer plutôt vos
propositions pour le cadre de vie si la
ville des mureaux et urbaniser en grande
partie elle n'en reste pas moins bordée
par la scène et le parc naturel régional
du vexin honore sa partie est et aussi
boisé avec le bois de belleville la
question du cadre de vie est évidemment
aussi liée à celle des transports en
2024 le rer e doit arriver aux mureaux
les travaux ont débuté tout récemment
c'est une préoccupation aujourd'hui
majeur des habitants l'environnement le
cadre de vie
je vais commencer avec vous daniela ruah
vos propositions sur ce sujet là le
cadre de vie on pense plutôt que c'est
la vie tout court déjà et ça se passe
beaucoup dans le logement et le logement
dans le cadre de vie c'est c'est surtout
ce qu'ils on voit autour de nous c'est
le manque de logements ces deux
logements dont les loyers trop chers et
donc le logement trop petit bain tout ça
on peut repeindre sa c
c'est nécessaire et c'est bien de le
faire mais ça suffit pas il faut aller
plus loin
il ya beaucoup de logements inoccupés
tout ça c'est de la spéculation la
spéculation pour maintenir les loyers
eau et bien sa mère il peut le dénoncer
il peut faire occuper les locaux pour
des loyers gratuits tant pis pour les
banques n'ont qu'à pas skip cas pas
spéculer et c'est ça qui fera baisser
les loyers occupé vraiment toutes les
surfaces les attribuer aux gens qui en
ont besoin et sur peut-être sur
l'environnement plus précisément même si
la réhabilitation et l'urbanisme c'est
lié à la thématique de l'écologie de
l'environnement
ce que vous avez des propositions là
dessus sur les mobilités ou autres
l'environnement
c'est pas compliqué c'est là c'est le
même raisonnement aujourd'hui pourquoi
on parle d'environnement
alors que toute l'industrie elle peut
elle pollue à tire larigot
on préfère mettre des camions sur les
routes plutôt qu'utiliser des trains
parce qu'on considère que c'est du flux
du flux tendu et du stock roule à plus
d'être plus d'ateliers plus de personnes
pour gérer les stocks
mais l'écologie on peut parler derrière
l'industrie démolit tout alors on peut
en parler on peut faire des ronds de
jambes là dessus de toute façon ceux qui
décident c'est pas dans les mairies
c'est dans les conseils d'administration
c'est au profit des actionnaires
alors on peut entretenir la parc c'est
bien qu'il l'ait faut il n'y a pas de
souza vous vous parlez d'un point de vue
national pour vous avez pas de moyens
d'action concrets au niveau d'une mairie
au niveau d'une mairie le maire un peu
fédérer les travailleurs autour de lui
encore une fois pour dénoncer les abus
des usines qui polluent les rivières ça
il y en a eu récemment c'est d'ailleurs
les mureaux est bordé la ville des
mureaux est bordé par à part la scène
oui et aériennes groupe a pompé
récemment des milliers de mètres cubes
de polluants qui était dans le sous-sol
depuis des dizaines d'années on pourrait
un liant justement la voix des
travailleurs qui eux savent ce genre de
choses mais on leur donne pas le droit
de le dénoncer
on pourrait agir oui beaucoup plus
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on fait
aujourd'hui la vérité dans cette
campagne vous un style vous insistez
beaucoup sur sur les transports voulait
notamment arrêter la politique anti
voitures en centre-ville et régler les
problèmes d'embouteillages sur le pont
de meulan avec une
aman une passerelle piétonne alors si on
parle qualité de la vie ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que ça revient
systématiquement dans la bouche de tous
les habitants lorsque laurent par là moi
je constate que un grand nombre
d'habitants n'aime plus cette vie n'aime
plus le cadre de vie de cette ville et
puis il ya des personnes qui ont passé
toute leur vie dans cette ville qui
arrive ça l'âge de la retraite qu'est ce
qu'ils me disent ils vous disent
n'attend plus qu'une chose c'est quitter
la ville et pourquoi
et bah pourquoi parce qu'en fait ils
n'aiment plus ce que la ville est
devenue par rapport à ce qu'ils ont
connu il ya quelques années donc ce
qu'il faut que vous l'avez dit s'est
améliorée notamment le logement et le
logement dans la maison mais aussi
l'environnement proche du logement moi
ce que je propose c'est que dans toutes
les zones où il ya notamment les zones
pavillonnaires où il ya des maisons
aujourd'hui ce sont des zones qui durant
les mandats précédents ont été des
quartiers oubliés dont je vais
construire dans ces zones des parcs pour
les enfants étaient city stade de
manière à ce que les enfants puissent un
peu sortir de leur environnement
familial et puis après il ya les zones
hlm les eaux nationales
aujourd'hui ce qui se passe dans un
grenier hlm c'est juste humainement
scandale moi j'apprends qu'il ya des
cafards dans d autres chemins les
fenêtres ne marche plus il ya plus de
chauffage aux plus beaucoup et c'est
tellement humide que les enfants ils ont
de l'asthme toute l'année donc moi je
suis allé voir les certains bailleurs
sociaux je les connais bien
donc ce que je vais leur dire si je
passe mer c'est que stop c'est fini je
ne construit plus un seul logement
social façon on en a déjà beaucoup trop
là justement que peut-être que si les
chiffres pour pour ceux qui regardent la
ville des mureaux c'est environ 12 mille
logements sur la commune dont plus de 40
% de logements sociaux ce qui était un
taux évidemment très élevé puisque la
loi impose 25% mais si c'est des
constructions historiques
non et on ne renie pas l'histoire c'est
pas le sujet et moi ce que je dis c'est
que je dirais aux bailleurs sociaux que
je ne construirai plus un seul logement
social tant qu'ils n'ont pas remis de
logements actuels dans des conditions de
sécurité et de qualité digne humainement
qui vous avez raison la qualité de la
liste si le transport moi quand j'écoute
les grands anciens ils me disent que le
problème de ce fameux pont de meulan qui
est tout le temps bouteiller ça existe
depuis 20 30 40 piges email trouver
quelqu'un qui m'a dit que ça aix depuis
50 ans cependant pas
je pense qu'en 20 ans on a largement le
temps de régler le problème
ce que je propose c'est de créer
effectivement une passerelle piétonne on
me dit que c'est pas possible
mantes-la-jolie l'a fait après cette
passerelle piétonne me permettra de
récupérer le trottoir pour créer une
troisième voie de circulation puis je
prend un arrêté municipal pour empêcher
la circulation des poids lourds afin de
donner priorité aux voitures
et enfin je fais le contournement de la
ville pour le flux de transit entre
l'autoroute a13 et à 15 par gargenville
qui a déjà l'infrastructure deux fois
double voies et nicolas brisson vous
avez du coup pas mal de retard sur les
autres candidats vos propositions sur le
cadre de vie lequel sont quelles
sont-elles mois dans le cadre de vie je
voulais parler de sécurité si c'est
possible donc on libre à vous de dire ce
que ce que vous souhaitez si on
m'autorise non c'est sûrement prochain
tracts donc on va en fait parler de
mesures prochaines mesures c'est que si
vous m'élisez mère je sais que le
problème de sécurité dans la ville est
un gros problème pour la plupart des
habitants et ça fait encore partie des
sujets les plus importants pour les
français lors de ces élections
municipales je compte augmenter le
nombre d'effectifs des policiers
municipaux et de pouvoir les équipes et
donc en deux premiers temps de police de
pistolets de type taser pour qu'il
puisse se défendre et pour dans un
deuxième temps ceux qui le souhaitent
être armés d'armes de poing donc voilà
ça c'est pour la partie sécurité je
voulais aussi parlé des parcs donc la
ville comme de nombreux parcs ses
membres parc
assez méconnu finalement voit refusée
par les médias c'est pas tout le
toujours l'image qu'on a des mureaux où
il ya pas mal de fans
après donc ça sera aussi une mesure des
parcs ce serait de les rendre un peu
plus agréable pour que les personnes
avec des familles puissent y accéder
puis rajouter un petit parc s'il faut
dans une partie pavillonnaire du grand
ouest parce que là on est un petit
manque de ce côté là quand vous dites
rendre agréable des parcs vous pensez à
vous améliorer l'entretien on va dire
meilleur entretien et si on peut rendre
on va dire des aires de jeu un peu plus
on va dire plus correct pour les enfants
est-ce que vous avez des propositions
peut être sûr sur les bords de seine
concrètement hervé riou alors vous
prévenir
j'avais de l'avancé en terme de temps de
parole c'est pour vous c'est pour la
suite vidéo du débat on va les aménager
moi je rêve du jour où le week-end les
habitants de la ville des mureaux et
puis les habitants des villes
avoisinantes viendront se promener sur
les bords de la seine aux mureaux et
pour boire un petit café
voilà donc on va les aménager de manière
à ce que les commerces s'installent sur
ce bord de seine toutes vivantes les
bords de cette morale à tout en
préservant évidemment l'environnement
daniel larrouy sur cette question des
bords de seine c'est quand même assez
atypique pour une ville c'était une
force sur le dossier mais qu'à répondre
là sur les logements sociaux parce que
je trouve quand même complètement fou
qu'on puisse dire qu on ne construira
pas de logements supplémentaires tant
que les bailleurs n'ont pas rêver non
pas rénové mais c'est la double peine
d'abord on n'a pas de logement et
ensuite tant que c'est pas rénové par
l'eba par les bailleurs cérétanes du
bailleur n'ont pas décidé eux de mettre
du pognon de la dame
ah ben on en comptera pas d'autres biens
pour les locataires pour les gens qui
habitent là c'est la double peine non
seulement y en a pas mais en plus ils
vont se dégrader qu'on continue à se
dégrader
parce qu'il faudra justement aller
chercher ces bailleurs et leur imposer
de rénover et à partir de là on pourra
avancer mais ça ne se pourra se faire
que si on leur impose parce que sinon
ils ne feront pas ils ne feront pas
comme iphone à toute l'économie leur a
posées par la mobilisation des occupants
par la mobilisation des habitats et ça
c'est le rôle du maire justement de
s'occuper de sa ville avec sa population
justement contre ceux qui viennent
d'ailleurs qui viennent de
du système économique qui font du pognon
sur notre dos mais leur dire vous avez
amassé des milliards pendant des années
maintenant vous rénovez c'est votre rôle
c'est le rôle que vous avez voulu
prendre et nicolas brisson sur cette
question à des logements sociaux qui
soulève visiblement assez de débats
autour de cette table
quelle est votre position opposition
tout simplement c'est qu'il y à beaucoup
sur la ville des mureaux oui il ya
beaucoup trop de logements sociaux
donc c'est vrai que c'est dommage pour
cette partie de la population
mais le problème c'est ce qui peut ce
qui entraîne derrière la pose du chômage
et tout ça c'est si on laisse trop de
partis
oula une population pauvre c'est pas
comme ça qu'on va réussir à les faire
aller faire s'élever en fait c'est ça
que je veux dire donc ça peut être un
problème donc si mon autre but à nous ça
serait d'arrêter de construire logements
sociaux sur les mureaux pendant un
certain temps pour pouvoir baisser un
petit peu ce pourcentage qui est énorme
je voulais revenir sur les bords de
seine par content parce que c'est un
sujet très important on a des mains des
bords de seine cc je ne comprends pas
pourquoi n'y a pas déjà actuellement des
choses pour boire comme heures vous
comment parler je rejoins sur ça je ne
comprends pas comment ça se fait qu'à
cette heure ci il n'y a toujours rien
qui est fait pour qu'on puisse boire un
café sur une terrasse en été
donc voilà c'est je suis assez m donc
ouais j'ai passé des bords de seine au
logement peut être que hervé riou vous
souhaitez relever
bonjour je viens à peine revenu au bord
de seine omar silawi bon ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que aujourd'hui dans les
bâtiments qui concerne de logements
sociaux c'est pas la peine d'en
construire d'autres temps il ya plein de
logements qui sont vides donc déjà
essayé de voir ceux qui sont
actuellement inoccupés safran une
capacité complémentaire et puis si vous
souhaitez en construire d'autres
c'est ce que vous avez dit est-ce que
vous resterez garant financier est prêt
bancaire de ses bailleurs
oui ou non je ne sais pas dans quel
terme on pourra le décider à un accord
avec la population et qu'un accord avec
les milliards jusque-là signale que ces
listes qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
classique quoique et apparemment où il
voulait pas faire leurs jeux financés
comme vous le des problèmes excusez moi
pour dire que les mairies en fait seront
systématiquement des rangs financier de
tous les prêts immobiliers que feront
les bailleurs donc je veux juste savoir
si la cohérence étaient dans le discours
et dans les actes peut-être si vous
souhaitez ajouter monsieur harvey
quelque chose très rapidement sur ce
sujet après on passera à la dernière
thématique l'adex c'est très important
qu'il y ait effectivement et ben alors
parfait parfaite transition merci
dernières grandes thématiques de ce
débat
un sujet qui fait justement débat depuis
de nombreuses années aux mureaux c'est
la dette de la ville selon des données
publiques du ministère de l'action et
des comptes publics la dette communale
s'élève à en 2018 à 81 8 millions
d'euros soit 2700 euros par habitant
contre 1000 euros en moyenne pour des
villes de la même taille
cette dette était de 39 millions d'euros
il y a dix ans 39 millions d'euros
seulement entre guillemets il ya dix ans
la majorité municipale qui n'est pas
présente un pour ce débat et notamment
françois gare est maire depuis 2001
évoquent le coût de la rénovation
urbaine et les fonds que la ville doit
avancer avant le remboursement de l'anru
agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine et affirme donc que cette dette
devrait se stopper de plus creusé
quelles sont vos propositions sur sur
cette dette est ce que c'est un sujet
pour vous majeur ou alors vous partager
l'avis du maire il n'y a pas à
s'inquiéter nicolas bridault c'est un
point sur lequel vous insistez dans
cette campagne
oui donc pour moi ce oui ça fait partie
d'une des priorités
la dette est énorme et elle est de 79
millions d'euros actuellement où j'ai 10
88 mais effectivement c'est 81 millions
d'euros en 2009 actuellement actuelle y
arrive
donc voilà c'est au niveau des chiffres
et des décalages mais en voile et de 80
millions d'euros aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui donc
voilà c'est un sujet majeur donc nous
voilà tout le dépensons ça sera des
priorités on ne veut pas construire
d'autres infrastructures actuellement
pour le mandat futur je veux dire il n'y
aura pas d'autres infrastructures qui
sera construit pour pouvoir baisser ce
taux d'endettement par contre il faut
pas faire de bêtises oui les écoles
doivent être au mieux
pas d'investissement sauf sur les écoles
c'est pas les avis et pas
d'investissement nouveau je veux dire en
construction le dôme et abily par dessus
tout la réalisation et c'est super
important et puis plus on va laisser
traîner les choses et plus ça va être
catastrophique
après sur ça
comme je vois mes concurrents c'est là
le problème sur ça c'est qu'ils
promesses des promesses et promet ses
promesses le problème c'est que la ville
est endettée et donc j'aimerais bien
juste savoir comment monsieur rioux va
va enfin alors on va financer cette
question justement directement et
peut-être comment vous est ce que vous
comptez faire des réductions de budget
sur sur certaines thématiques et sujet
de dont la mairie est à la maîtrise il
peut y avoir une réorganisation des
services donc c'est réorganisation des
services c'est faire mieux avec moins
je pense que c'est tout à fait possible
aujourd'hui les les employés municipaux
il y en a énormément donc le problème
des chiffres c'est que là et c'est entre
850 et 1000 si j'ai bien compris
j'ai pas léger pas les chiffres là le
problème c'est qu'il ya je pense
quelques maires qui a les chiffres
exacts est exact et puis il est assez
floue souvent dans les conseils
municipaux donc réduire la nation en
gros deux salariés public voilà par les
départs à la retraite c'est ne plus
embaucher s'aimer réorganiser les
services pour que les choses puissent se
passer au mieux par août hervé riou du
coup puisqu'on vous interpeller sur le
sujet je sais que c'est aussi un point
important votre campagne comment réduire
cette dette bas côtés de the fall a payé
pourquoi est-ce qu'on en est arrivé là
henin qui évoque des raisons ça surement
le convainquent pas j'observe d'ailleurs
que le maire actuel françois gay a
réalisé des jo en 2014 que la dette
serait réglé leur double 17 force est de
constater que ce n'est pas le cas donc
on comptait 10 en 2020 que la dette sera
remboursée en 2025 ou 2030 j'arrive pas
le constat qu'elle se stabilisera et
bref donc 200 pour la romance est alors
de moyens là en bon c'est parce que moi
je pars il
je veux éviter la mise sous tutelle soit
on augmente les impôts sur notre autre
solution moi il est hors de question
d'augmenter les impôts qui sont déjà
trop has fiction pour la population donc
faut trouver d'autres solutions
comment je trouve d'autres solutions je
vends du terrain si la solution
je vends du foncier qui appartient à la
mairie je le vend à un prix qui est le
prix et du marché et ça va très vite et
on veut rembourser la dette
l'intérêt de vente du foncier et donc du
terrain c'est que du coup on peut avec
des amis
j ai des promoteurs aussi en profiter
pour créer des grands projets
d'infrastructure structurant pour la
ville pour le centre ville pour les
quais de seine pour les entrées de la
ville pour transformer l'image des
mureaux voilà comment je vends du
foncier daniela ruah sur cette question
de la dette des mureaux ben faut se
poser d'abord la question cette dette
d'où elle sort elle sort des budgets et
des transferts de charges de l'état vers
les communes donc les communes ont de
plus en plus un scope de bien plus grand
de choses à faire et les finances ne
sont ne suivent pas de la partie
après on a aussi toutes ces entreprises
privées s'est mise entreprises
milliardaire qui s'engraissent sur le
dos des communes en construisant
justement des choses avec des mairies
qui se portent garants se porter garant
d'entreprise milliardaire
non mais vous ayez par exemple aller
chercher de l'argent chez ariane groupe
qui est sûre les mureaux bien sûr des
milliardaires ils veulent faire maigrir
leur pression ils veulent faire des
choses qu'ils les fassent ils n'ont pas
besoin d'une mairie pour être garant il
veut le faire du bénéfice
qu'il le fasse c'est pas la mairie de
leur donner le bénéfice c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est la mairie qui
finance le circuit de bus le numéro 4 il
ya que des salariés d'ariane groupe qui
le prennent pourquoi séparer groupe qui
paye nicolas bref sont sur ce sujet je
voulais revenir déjà sur la fameuse
vente d
du foncier bon là c'est un truc qu'on
n'est pas forcément d'accord c'est parti
fonciers peuvent servir pour les
prochaines infrastructures à construire
ou pour l'aménagement de nouveaux parcs
je pense que la ville ait amplement
assez urbanisées voilà et après donc je
n'ai toujours pas eu de réponse parce
que j'ai eu beaucoup de sur les tracts
de monsieur rioux de choses qu'il va
faire le problème c'est que j'ai jamais
eu de tracts sur comment il va les
financer
donc voilà sachant que c'est sur votre
temps de parole ensuite libre à vous de
répondre évidemment soit simple geste
soutien de la communauté urbaine du
département et surtout de la région et
ceux qui financent l'ensemble des
projets structurants de la ville que
vous avez eu effectivement dans les
trappes dans mes tracts et bien ça ne
coûtera pas un seul centime aux mureaux
puisque sera payé par les collectivités
territoriales
daniel la rue vous pouvez encore
peut-être rebondir là dessus
quelques secondes après on enchaînera
sur la sur la conclusion de chacun un
jeune quand j'entends quelqu'un qui se
positionne comme le futur maire dire qui
va réorganiser les services qui va
baisser le nombre d'employés je crois
entendre un patron mais bon une fois les
finances qui manque c'est pas la faute
des salariés c'est pas la foi des gens
qui s'occupent de l'entretien de la
ville
c'est la faute des finances qui
n'arrivent pas par le gouvernement alors
qu'ils nous filent plus de boulot à
faire
on approche donc de la fin de cette
émission avec la conclusion une carte
blanche vous serez libres d'aborder le
sujet que vous souhaitez peut-être
revenir sur un point du débat peut-être
une nouvelle thématique votre conclusion
est corrélé aussi à vos temps de parole
on commence avec vous daniel larrouy
puisque vous aviez terminé le tour
d'introduction vous commencer ce tour de
conclusion vous avez une minute 30
maximum d'accord une municipalité
comment je viens de le décrire elle peut
pas tout gérer dans la vie par contre le
maire les élus s'ils sont des élus
militants de la classe ouvrière
ils peuvent fédérer autour d'eux ils
peuvent rassembler ils peuvent organiser
la wii sommes avec la population avec
les travailleurs de la ville les choses
de tous les points de vue les
travailleurs ils font tout dans cette
société là ils sont capables de tout et
surtout de savoir au plus près quels
sont leurs besoins et comment le faire
il sait pas à travers des conseils
d'administration qu'on peut pourra aller
à ce niveau-là de détails à ce niveau-là
de précisions
et de répondre aux besoins et c'est ça
qui nous guidera les besoins de la
population de la classe ouvrière des
travailleurs hervé riou vous êtes le
deuxième à conclure vous avez une
cinquantaine de secondes moins de temps
alors moi ce que je souhaite à travers
les différentes propositions que j'ai
mais c'est construire une ville des
mureaux où enfin l'investissement est
mis dans les écoles c'est construire une
ville des mureaux où l'emploi revient à
travers l'interactivité économique une
ville où il ya plus trop là me
transporte une ville où il fait bon
vivre une ville on retrouve une qualité
digne et des logements humain une ville
où le service est revenu auprès des
habitants et enfin une ville où le
dialogue et la confiance entre les
habitants et les élus sont restaurés
tout ça ça ne prend pas 20 ans pour le
faire il faut juste du courage de la
volonté et du soutien pour les tic y
pour y arriver
et bien moi j'ai le courage la volonté
je vous assure que dans mon équipe qui
m'entoure
nous l'avons et le soutien je le
soutiens en deux les trois collectivités
qui nous entoure nicolas brisson une
minute 55 pour conclure moi je vais donc
re re parler de mon programme donc si
vous voulez une baisse d'impôts donc je
parle des impôts locaux sur la commune
de -5%
si vous voulez avoir des policiers armés
de taser et pour ceux qui voudront un
peu plus tard armés d'armes de poing
pour pouvoir assurer la sécurité de la
ville 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
parce qu'une police municipale il se
passe aussi des choses la nuit je pense
que tout le monde est au courant
voilà voté pour moi j'ai voté pour nous
parce qu'il ya une liste derrière on n'a
pas parlé également de coeur de ville
c'est un sujet qui est très important
donc nous on veut servir de coeur de
ville pour pouvoir avoir les commerces
de proximité qui manque cruellement aux
habitantes qui concernera aussi les
bords de seine
donc c'est quelque chose qui va être
très important c'est quelqu'un qui est
ce quelque chose qui va être là pour les
40 prochaines années
donc c'est un sujet qu'on a on tient à
coeur à pouvoir réaliser avec vous
nos priorités seront d'organiser des
réunions de quartier donc tous les ans
chaque année passée faire des réunions
dans tous les quartiers si on est élu
pour avoir toutes là tout ce que les
habitants de chacun de ces quartiers
voudront nous dira tout ce qui leur
importe c'est voilà merci
si vous pouvez voter pour nous
rassemblement national on est là voilà
la liste qui était en tête aux
européennes et j'espère être en tête aux
municipales également merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat du
premier tour pour les élections
municipales aux mureaux on va peut-être
voir une dernière fois les temps de
parole s'afficher cette presque égalité
on essaiera un maximum de rééquilibrer
tout ça mais globalement entre 10 et 11
minutes
je rappelle que vous serez opposés à
deux autres candidats françois garay
tête de liste les mureaux ville à vivre
et à nier c'est dans la tête de lice
agir aux mureaux ces deux candidats je
vous le rappelle n'ont pas voulu se
déplacer pour ce débat encore merci du
coup avoue 3 de faire vivre le débat
démocratique cette émission est à revoir
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile elle est aussi à
réécouter sur sensation yvelines pour
rappel le premier tour aura lieu le 15
mars prochain en attendant la campagne
se poursuit elle est notamment à suivre
sur notre antenne et notre site internet
merci
[Musique]